I didn't buy a Wii uh I moved in with my
friend about 18 months ago and just in
front of the TV there was the Wii U and
I remember at the time I I thought I'm
never going to play that it was I really
had no interest in it in fact I was at
the time saying like Nintendo should
abandon the whole thing and just start
again I was I was that against it
basically and 18 months later it's the
console I play more than any other the
best thing about owning a Wii U is
having access to Nintendo properties
like Mario Zelda and even sort of
third-party exclusive like Bayonetta 2
you know those aren't really ever going
to come to another platform you're not
going to see a Mario game on a Sony
console or a Microsoft console at least
not in the near future so if you want
those awesome classic Nintendo games and
we use the only place to get them and
that's easily the best thing about
having one my favorite thing about
having a Wii U is it's become my default
console for playing with my son I've got
a five-year-old and most of the games
that I tend to play with them are Wii uh
exclusives so it's been you know it's
been that sort of stable go-to for like
nice kid-friendly Activity one of the
best things about it for me personally
is like really that the the the fact
that you can play a game on the second
screen on the GamePad because like when
you live in a house with other people
it's it's really rough
um to share the TV and just being able
to play say like a few rounds of Mark on
online like while someone else is
watching telly or what have you is like
really handy and I would kind of wish
more consoles did that better like the
Vita does it but it's not as good as a
Nintendo fan I feel like it was 100
worth it like I always know what I'm
getting out of a Nintendo system and
it's going to be Nintendo games I don't
buy it with the expectation that I'm
going to be playing like Call of Duty
and Assassin's Creed and all those big
name games I buy it to play Mario and
Zelda and the franchises that they do
really well and as much as they hyped
the Wii U beforehand to to make it seem
like this is going to be a third party
console this is going to be the thing
that competes but the PS3 and Xbox 360.
it's not it's still that second console
that you own because Nintendo just makes
really fun games I told myself
a couple months ago if the Wii U had
five good games I would purchase a Wii U
H Bayonetta two Super Mario 3D worlds
Mario Kart Ace Lego City Undercover I
kind of want to play
101 what is it called again what
Wonderful 101 thank you that's five I
don't currently own
ER we do have one in the house
have a phase where every weekend it
would be Pikmin 3 Mario Kart going
online playing Mario Kart 8 and then
recently it's just dropped off even with
the release of Bayonetta 2
there's I want to play it but there's
just something there that's not making
me want to use the system I don't know
what it is my view on the Wii U is it's
kind of like when you were a kid and
there was your your best friend who had
that amazing toy and you go around to
their house and you play it and you have
a great time and you come home but you'd
never never liked it enough to want to
spend lots of your pocket money on it so
it's that kind of thing for me I enjoy
it but I have pretty much zero interest
in getting one even for the multiplayer
stuff like Mario Kart Super Mario 3D
World I don't find myself with enough
time or to or I don't find myself in
those situations where I'm going to have
three people around who all want to sit
down and play Mario Kart for an hour or
something so it's just not the kind of
party console that can slot into my
lifestyle at the moment as much as I
love the Wii U and the games that come
out for it I think the system has a lot
of issues for one the GamePad is a
horrible controller the screen itself is
too low res and washed out for my tastes
and it loses battery life really quickly
plus it makes the system far more
expensive than it needs to be because
it's included with every single one
likewise I'm a little disappointed in in
Nintendo's Virtual Console support it
did a great job with the Wii when that
first came out for the first like couple
years and then it started to Peter off
now I think that one of the great things
they have is this Legacy and by sort of
leaving that on the table and not
bringing it to the system faster maybe
it's a licensing issue maybe it's
something else I don't know but by not
doing a better job of that I think
they're missing out on something that
makes them truly unique which is having
these libraries they can tap into so as
much as I I love the software that that
Nintendo puts out they're still so far
behind in terms of internet connectivity
and understanding how the infrastructure
of something like this should work like
the fact that the Nintendo eShop only
recently tied in with the 3dse shop in
terms of of money like the money that
you put into your 3DS is going to be
applicable to your Wii U as well but the
games aren't and that drives me insane
that if you want to buy the original
Mario Brothers you have to buy a version
for the Wii U and you have to buy a
version for your 3DS and those games
they're so simplistic I just want all of
that to be tied together and I really
really want it for Earthbound which is
right now on Wii U and probably the best
reason to buy a Wii U I can't buy it on
my 3DS and which is that that's where I
really want to play it what's really
going to do it for me and just say that
the Wii U has finally arrived is when
Smash Brothers comes out next week but
ultimately when we get the next Zelda
title I think that is where Nintendo
does their most interesting and exciting
work and last year we only saw the first
glimpse of the new Zelda Wu title so
idioneuma the producer says that we're
going to see more next year so give it
about another year and I think the Wii U
will definitely be a must-own console
personally I get most of what I need
from games out of the PlayStation 4
slash XBox One I can't even really
recommend either over the other because
they're largely the same and most of the
games are on both consoles
um but yeah between that and the PC and
you know random mobile stuff it's quite
a lot of video games to play there so
like the Wii U was only ever going to
grab me if there was stuff on there that
I really wanted to play which I can't
play anywhere else and it turns out that
that's what Nintendo's been doing for
about
30 years so now there are enough games
to come out on it and I'm gonna bite the
bullet
foreign